hello lovely people I'm Alana and
welcome to another episode of good
gaming news which is a weekly gaming
news show where I talk about all the
good news and video games because there
are enough people on YouTube trying to
get clicks talking about negative news I
know people don't want to watch positive
news as much but I'm giving it to the
people who want to have a good time
anyway I appreciate you being here the
first story this week is one that I'm
personally extremely excited about and
that is Ninja Gaiden and Dead or Alive
reboots are in the works what is this
posture that's very confusing is it not
is that not are you both okay scoliosis
across the board in both of these
franchises to be honest but also if you
didn't already know this
ayane who is in both dead or alive and
Ninja Gaiden he's my favorite female
video game character and has been for a
really long time I love how the pits so
this is from noisypixel.net and the
story itself says during team Ninja's
keynote at the Korea g-star conference
they remarked upon various subject
matters ranging from their design
philosophy to their worldwide appeal
however their most noteworthy comments
were at the end of the conference where
they reveal that reboots for the Beloved
dead or alive and Ninja Gaiden series
are in the works let's go I don't know
that my life has that much of a place
for Dead or Alive anymore I'll always
take some titty physics I just feel like
that maybe that franchise is not one
that I have a huge lust to have more
from personally never my favorite
fighting game series good time but I'm
okay without it Ninja Gaiden however I
will take more Ninja Gaiden as long as
it's good Ninja Gaiden I guess for the
rest of my life you can keep giving me
Ninja Gaiden I I love it so good and I
think also the reason that I and
probably a lot of other people
well like
okay with playing very difficult games
Ninja Gaiden is hard and I think Ninja
Gaiden is actually the franchise that
gave me my love that I have for playing
games on the hottest difficulty or
trying to get through really challenging
video games it definitely spocked that
in me and I was very proud of myself
when I finished the first one on the
hardest difficulty it was real hard so
it does say that no specific details
regarding these projects were stated
which they weren't but we do have just
some nice images from the conference
here and that is ultimately the whole
story a very quick one to start with but
one that I feel very positively about
all the same
next up this story is from eurogamma and
more of a feature the news but still
something that I really wanted to
highlight because obviously it's a
course that I care a lot about
um this is meet the man making control
is accessible for everyone Caleb cropped
on modifications helping others and what
Sony and code can do next the story says
last week I sat down to meet with Caleb
craw from the controller project it has
to be said that craft is quite a fitting
surname for Caleb as he is a craft by
name and he is certainly a Craftsman by
Nature nice work hero gamer nice I hope
you're proud of yourself cross charity
the controller project creates free
downloadable blueprints to modify
established controllers such as the
PlayStation 5's dual sense or the
Nintendo switch's Joy cons for players
to
you know what
this is such a funny thing
um this is like a style guide that I got
when I was working at IGN because I came
because I was working there when the
switch came out uh the plural of joy-con
is joy-con you're not allowed to say Joy
cons it's joy-con
no such thing as Joy Cons with an S
um in any case for players with
disabilities or limb differences in
addition to this it also uses 3D
printing to crop these modifications and
send them out to those who need them
which is just such a cool thing to do
for people and such an important thing
about accessibility is just considering
everybody it is almost impossible to
fully cater to every
accessibility need just with
accessibility settings you do also have
to make changes to Hardware you have to
add new settings all the time it is a a
thing that in order to include
absolutely everybody has to be made as
expansive as possible and so the fact
that somebody is doing this um as part
of a charity is just so unbelievably
cool and valuable
um the controller project all started 10
years ago with a young boy named Thomas
apparently I first heard about Thomas
tree my wife who was a teacher at craft
tells me he has Muscular Dystrophy and
this was impacting his ability to play
Minecraft something he loved at this
point in time craft was looking to
generate interest for a site named
hackaday which focused primarily on
electronic projects crafts or Thomas's
story is a good opportunity to pull in
some traffic he was already tinkering
and Building Things as a hobby anyway so
if he could make this boy a custom
controller this would be an easy way to
get some eyes on the site now I know
that is an incredibly insensitive and
horrible thing to do craft admits but at
the time I just thought hey you know it
tugs on the hot springs it's a good
project and it helps us get out there
I'll make a video of this which bold of
him to admit yeah not I not ideal
circumstances however when Kraft went to
visit Thomas in his home his attitude
changed I saw the reality of the
situation and it really impacted me
crafter calls I felt a huge need to help
in any way that I could following the
visit to Thomas's craft began making his
first custom controller and he has been
doing it ever since and this is what
they look like these are extended
triggers that allow for different hand
positions and here's the thing that I
I'll say about accessibility forever
people think that accessibility is a
thing that only disabled people need and
there are several ways to tackle this
topic but one thing that I've been
trying to tell people recently is that
disability can mean a lot of things a
disability is not necessarily something
that you were inherently born with when
I came off a motorbike and I couldn't
use my hands that was a disability I
faced temporarily a temporary disability
I couldn't walk very well and I had a
lot of trouble playing video games
because any anything touching sort of
around my thumb area was extremely
painful so that's the thing that could
happen to you at any time at any time
you could have an injury to your hands
potentially even a permanent one that
would prevent you from being able to
play the games you love temporary
disability there are also situational
disabilities such as a parent trying to
play Elder ring but they have a
two-year-old who's running around the
house and they can't pause the game in
the middle of the boss fight that lack
of accessibility means that that game is
much more difficult for people who have
kids or maybe people who have a puppy
people who have something else that
needs their attention is inherently
inaccessible to people who are playing a
game that doesn't have a pause option so
that's a situational disability you are
unable to do something because of the
situation that you're in that can also
apply to playing a game on a plane if it
relies really heavily on audio cues
unless you can't hear the audio very
well because planes are so loud or
whatever maybe your headphones suck
we've all been there you have a
situational disability so stuff like
this is awesome not only for people who
have things like muscular dystrophy or
atrophy but also for everyone else I
could have used something like this when
I came off the motorbike probably a lot
easier than the regular grip and so if
you're a person who's previously been
opposed to accessibility I just want you
to think about it in that way but you
shouldn't have to think about yourself
um but I I respect that this guy also
thought of that that craft also you know
trying to use it as something and then
understood it but that it could also be
really important to you in the future
and we want to make sure that everybody
can keep playing video games and as you
get older things get harder as your
reaction time slow down even I just feel
like we should reframe accessibility as
it's not something that is for the
disabled bolt even if it is disability
is much bigger than you think but it is
more about customizing and having as
many customization options as possible
and customization is awesome in any case
sorry back to the story in the 10 years
since its conception the controller
project has recruited over 100
volunteers across the world who use
their time and skills to come up with
new customizations and when required
print off the necessary pieces needed to
modify a controller for those with
access to a 3D printer there is a whole
catalog of these modification designs
available to download through the
controller project many of which
actually offer very minor adjustments
that just tweak a controller slightly
and these are the ones the small
customizations to help make gameplay
more comfortable for users have the
widest user demand which makes sense
even I have pain from holding controller
too long because my hands are big and
the controller is small crop set it's
just simple things such as a bigger grip
to fit my hands probably would make me
an able-bodied person just better able
to play games exactly it's for everybody
make accessibility accessible this is
really cool stands that hold a
controller in place for the use at a
specific height and location that's
that's really really neat how awesome is
that it's a leg mounted controller that
allows you to play games without having
to grip the controller how awesome you
say then there are modifications that
completely remap the controller here
craft draws attention to a design by
engineer akaki kumeri kumeri has
designed a modification kit that allows
the controller to be used with a single
hand which is awesome as well uh God of
War Ragnarok is playable with just one
hand I think last of us part one and
part 2 are as well but it's pretty
uncommon and very very difficult to pull
off and requires a lot of play testing
so this is just so awesome very cool
I'll leave a link in the description to
this article
um so that you can get some more detail
I just really wanted to give it a shout
out because it's just such a such an
awesome thing to do and such a valuable
world to give more exposure to and to
talk about more and that's why I keep
doing it next up this is a story I
covered forever ago that uh we're
covering again today Val Patton's new VR
controller with Quest like tracking ring
I'm a big fan of VR you probably already
know that about me if you're here I
really enjoy it I use it all the time
still waiting for our valve to come out
with fully Wireless VR in terms of like
no PC needed especially after Gabe
Newell made a comment that was something
along the lines of like we did it with
steam deck why can't we do it with our
VR I'm very excited to see what they
have in store so a new patent for a new
VR controller with Quest like tracking
ring is pretty exciting and I love the
quest controller I think it's great
there's definitely functionality that I
think the Vive does better I mean across
the board but the ring tracking is
awesome and can let you do really cool
stuff so sorry yes index I realize I'm
still saying five in any case this is
what I was talking at but I'll first
mentioned investing in a new headset
last year and strongly hinted at it
having onboard compute to run Standalone
without the need for a PC when
discussing steam decks technology in
February CEO Gabe and you're amused why
can't I have that in a tetherless
integrated VR Solution that's exactly
what I was talking about late last year
YouTuber Brad Lynch found references to
a new headset model codename decade in
the steambr driver files ARS Technica
said it's sources confirmed Tech its
existence and I think that's the story
that I had covered on the channel
previously a valve job listing posted
last month seeks an engineer to
prototype ship and support a headset
with Advanced tracking features and then
I guess this is what the new controller
would look like
I like the fat that's cool a lot of
buttons ooh now a patent awarded today
titled electronic controller with linear
hand strap adjuster which I guess is
this
depicts a new VR controller with index
like hand straps but it quests like
tracking ring very neat as the title
suggests the pattern is mainly focused
on the strap design allowing the user
let go of the controller to drop or
throw objects I love that because that's
such a weird thing to do in VR work like
really you always feel like you want to
let go but you can't because you're
holding something it it really does
throw you off a lot of the time
um
it also accommodates a range of
different hand shapes and the tracking
dots seen on the ring are described as
being either infrared IR LEDs to be
tracked by the headset or photo diodes
from steamvia Lighthouse based stations
and yeah the job listing posted last
month does suggest that valve is going
with headset-based computer vision
tracking and thus controls with ir LEDs
very exciting stuff and there was a
patent file in tune that revealed the
design of the headset strap so again a
lot of strap patterns but still very
excited next up another one from
Eurogamer today Assassin's Creed valhall
is headed to steam alongside other
Ubisoft titles 2 which is a story
um again very positively about very
happy to hear this one this one rules
because it means that another AAA
publisher is finally recognizing that
having your own store for everything
sucks butts that's right I said it I'm
aware that it's very harsh excessively
harsh but it does it sucks but and being
that this is I believe ubisoft's
currently most successful game
Assassin's Creed Valhalla is pretty huge
it's a good sign that you know we're
gonna just keep getting Ubisoft games on
Steam
available across the board the story
says ubisoft's Blockbuster Assassin's
Creed Valhalla will launch via Steam on
6th of December its publisher has
confirmed to Eurogamer today valhall is
coming to steam with other Ubisoft
titles such as city building strategy
Anno 1800 and free to play 3v3 sports
game roller Champions also set for
release on the platform albeit at a
currently unspecified date the
confirmation means Ubisoft is the latest
publisher to make its return to steam
after striking out on its own or
elsewhere such as the Rival epic game
store and I guess why epic game store is
concerned I am happy to have competition
for Steam and the epic game store as
much as Gamers hated and it is lacking
some important functionality and I don't
love the UI to be honest maybe just
because of me steam though it is very
good for developers they give devs a
better cut and gotta give that a shout
out because it's very Jew but
exclusivity for PC is just so ridiculous
just I get that you want to make 100 of
your profit start making me download a
million programs just put them on
everything at least give us the choice
you know uh it's such a move has been
signaled by several leaks including
listings for steam versions of
Assassin's Creed Valhalla and roller
Champions spotted in code for ubisoft's
own connect launcher and a subsequent
steam database listing for the latter
we're constantly evaluating how to bring
our games to different audiences
wherever they are while providing a
consistent player ecosystem through
Ubisoft connect to Ubisoft spokesperson
told Eurogamer today Assassin's Creed
Valhalla no 1800 and roller Champions
are among the Ubisoft titles that we'll
be releasing on Steam
Assassin's Creed Valhalla originally
launched the PC via Ubisoft connect and
the epic game store back in 2020. it is
one of the only games in the franchise
not released on Steam to date please
just put them on all of them please just
everything please come on now is a good
time for its arrival too as Ubisoft
prepares to launch its final update to
valhalla's extensive post launch program
on December 6 Valhalla will get a free
epilogue dubbed the Lost chapter which
will wrap up the game's final dangling
plot threads this patch will also signal
an end to the game's rotating seasonal
events and will not add a new games plus
mode just something I'm happy about
um I understand why they want epic
exclusive money I understand it because
they gave them money the answer is money
but I don't think many gamers are in
favor of it in general stop PC
exclusivity please it's so silly next up
we got some updates to the Halo Master
Chief Collection modding it's a status
update that is on their steam page and
it says if you've been looking to get
involved with modding Halo the mustard
collection there's never been a better
time than the present we've officially
made the first of several Publishers of
official mod documentation in a central
location you can find the information
here but it does actually it's pretty
extensive link but I won't actually go
through all of it it says you can
leverage these documents to dip your
toes into modding and arm yourself with
knowledge before forging ahead along
with the documentation and impending
Halo 4 and Halo 2 Anniversary mod tools
we will be introducing a tool to help
you create and upload your own mod
packages directly to the Steam Workshop
which is awesome cold accession this
tool will be coming to the MCC mod scene
in a further update and is intended to
help make creating sharing and
installing mods more accessible to the
community which is definitely kind of a
problem it's a little bit wonky I'm
happy to see this also really happy for
Forge to finally be a part of Halo
infinite
modern Community has always done very
cool stuff with every game but I also
just really love it with Halo they come
up some very very very cool game modes
the documentation is a work in progress
and will evolve over time for now you
can learn how to leverage accession and
get help modding with Halo 2 and Halo 3.
so we'll just click on it to look at but
I'm not going to go over any of this but
it is really cool that there's a Content
creation quick start and the accession
tool like this seems like a really good
way for anyone who is interested in
getting into modding to get into it they
have all these how-to guides script
references like it's just a really great
resource
in my opinion as somebody who has used a
lot of mods but has never modded myself
so maybe it's not and I don't know what
I'm talking about last but not least we
got an update on atomic heart a game I
was very late to uh catching up on but
then
um very quickly impressed by
um of course it is a shooter that looks
very bioshocky uh we did a reaction to a
new trailer maybe on last week's episode
I've done before yeah it looks very
bioshocky wolfensteiny
um it's it's a rewrite of Soviet history
in the way that Wolfenstein is of the
Nazis I suppose so this is by Simon
cardi and it says atomic heart wears its
influences on its sleeve it's a graphic
first person shooter packed with
superpower like abilities and it owes
lots to Classics of the genre Bioshock
and Half-Life both of which are very
good games though I guess in my head
Bioshock doesn't feel classic it doesn't
feel old enough it is pretty old at this
point oh I'm old however that doesn't
mean it hasn't gotten many of its own
unique ideas and surprises also hidden
up the same sleeve and from playing a
considerable amount of monfish's Debut I
found there's a lot to be excited about
and I've found that I'm very jealous of
you Simon Cody I would love to play this
game says its opening takes obvious cues
from Bioshock infinite's masterful
introduction to Colombia which I think
is probably like one of the best video
game intros of all time to be honest
even if I don't love Infinite anywhere
near as much as the original Bioshock
very let's see is the best Bioshock
changed my mind robots have been
integrated into society and helped
relieve the public from everyday
stresses and labor however of course the
AI turns not so friendly and the game
begins in Earnest it says it's not the
straight up Corridor shooter some may
envisage which I suppose I had nor a
sprawling open world full of Nooks to
explore or a puzzle-filled brain teaser
it's all of those things and more cool I
think in my head I sort of based on the
trailer I'm expecting
um in terms of the way the world
actually operates something along little
bit like modern prey
but I don't know where I got that from
the scope of atomic heart is impressive
seemingly unfolds and builds as you make
your way through its many distinct and
large sci-fi complexes over the course
of its 20 hour plus campaign noted
that's a pretty long time for this kind
of shootout Wolfenstein games aren't
that long nor was uh Bioshock or
Half-Life so that's pretty lengthy
atomicard's closest analog structurally
would be Halo infinite interesting
didn't expect that okay an open world
littered with Mobs of enemies and a
linear story and linear story dungeons
to dip in and out of that actually makes
me like it slightly less unfortunately
these dungeons are where majority of the
main missions lie and comprised of
learning more about the facility the
people behind it and what exactly has
gone wrong there you battle through
sections patrolled by Rogue AI units
before facing off against a challenging
boss Atomic hot isn't Reinventing the
wheel on this regard but definitely adds
its own Flair to the mix he mentions
that having a really distinctive art
style it's a gorgeous game pack with
Lush Forest eye-catching architecture
and Bonkers looking machinery and sounds
like there's some really good traversal
here driving ziplining swimming running
some more about combat here says it
frequently flips between frantic
firefights against unrushing hordes to
slow up more deliberate melee jewels
first and foremost it is a shooter and
it has an impressive collection of
firearms to back that up they range from
the relentlessly chattering AK-47 to
heavyweight RPGs then there are more
experimental things guns that blast out
electric bombs something that can only
be described as a large metal pole that
fires whirling blades that carve up
enemies before returning your hand some
kind of robot boomerang
okay okay so this is the part where we
get to the elemental powers which look
very interesting to me and very
bioshocky of course there's an
electrified shock of course there is
there's always got to be an electrified
shock telekinesis attacks
can lift groups of enemies into the air
before introducing them back to the
ground with a violent thud freezing an
enemy and then shattering them it's all
pretty standard stuff but always fun got
some new screenshots here hmm it's
almost a little bit Far Cry Oh I love
the aesthetic so cool that almost looks
like Crisis
see parade see
I'm not crazy another Valve game Atomic
Hearts appears to draw its influence
from his portal not from any of its
robot designs but the surprising
Revelation that puzzles play a
considerable part I didn't realize that
test sites uh puzzle boxes lasting
anywhere from 15 minutes to an hour to
complete
they're essentially abandoned lab
facilities requiring you to put combat
skills through a cerebral exam I love
that use your glove shock ability to
magnetize nodes they're not the most
challenging but provided a welcome
change from the pace nonetheless oh I
love I love a good puzzle that's awesome
weapons and abilities can be modified
and upgraded robots are all controlled
by a central AI that was always on the
lookout for you and ways combating its
glare include avoiding its cameras
either by disabling them or making the
glove performance best gravity gun
impression to hurl objects at it as a
distraction that's neat you've got an
alert level that's fun it's gonna be
tough for sure definitely challenging I
think finally it says the hours I've
spent with atomic heart have left me
yearning for more it's an engrossing
world to get lost in with Dynamic combat
and inspired art and enemy design I have
a few doubts of whether the main story
will deliver a tale worthy of such style
location and I've seen some heavy-handed
writing and performances that leave a
little to be desired always a bummer but
I don't think I was ever expecting to
play this for the story that said I
didn't expect that with the two new
Wolfenstein games and then they
delivered like a hell of a story so
there is also apparently a nauseating
forward roll animation that's a bummer
hopefully they can fix that but he also
said I can't say these grabs were ever
enough to fully take away from all the
things I found myself engaging with
along the way time will tell if atomic
heart lives up to its lofty aspirations
yeah just stoked to hear more about the
game comes out February next year at
least that's what it's scheduled for and
it does look very cool so I'll also link
this one in the description in case you
want to check it out and that is it for
me today everyone I hope you enjoyed
this episode of good gaming news I will
see you all next week bye